[Música]
podemos contarles de un sueño muy muy
particular en mi sueño y este sueño
precisamente inicia después de dos horas
de una película de ver una película que
se llama ahí está ella
la guerra de las galaxias' después de
pasar dos horas viendo robots naves
espaciales
robot
rayos láser más robots
y otros planetas
y robots robots robots salgo de la sala
de cine de la mano de mi madre lo
primero que le pregunto yo a mi madre al
salir del cine
es mamá que necesito estudiar yo para
que cuando sea grande pueda hacer
fabricar robots mi madre que hasta la
fecha es una mujer que siempre nos ha
hablado con la verdad a sus hijos a sus
tres hijos ella nos crió sola
me dice hijo para poder hacer para poder
estudiar algo que te lleve a hacer
robots tendrías que volver a nacer pero
en eeuu el sueño empieza y a los nueve
años de edad después de ver una película
y a los nueve años de edad pues empiezo
a ha decidido yo qué pasos tengo que dar
para crear robótica entonces me doy
cuenta que los robots se controlan con
electrónica se controlaban y se seguirán
controlando con la electrónica entonces
decido yo que el siguiente paso es
aprender de electrónica pero qué
electrónica potter yo a los nueve años
de edad que acceso posterior a la
electrónica y kabul
pues todo lo que era
a los rudos despertadores las radio
grabadoras
las televisiones los tocan cintas las
lavadoras de mi casa las destape
todos los abril
de repente mi madre decía
ahorita vengo voy al súper en una hora
de regreso off la tele nueva de verdad
destapaba la tele nueva oye pues me
regalaron una tarea su juego un aparato
medio extraño porque pues yo abría la
tarea y empezaba a conocer lo que era la
electrónica
pero no había nadie quien me guiara si
iba aprendiendo que hacía una cosa que
hacía otra cosa a veces hasta por
pequeños libros o manuales que conseguía
yo y empecé yo
a solicitar libros por correo por el
correo tradicional y libros que tardaban
cinco o seis meses en llegar
correcto más cinco o seis meses en
llegar y a veces llegaba y no era el
libro que tú querías o se equivocaban
allá o el título te note o te servía
mucho y lo pedía diferente bueno aquí
hago una pequeña pausa en mi sueño y
quiero decirle muchachos que si los que
tenemos esta edad logramos algo con
mucho esfuerzo a la edad que tenemos
pudimos hacer algo ustedes tienen una
gran ventaja sobre nosotros y es
esto se cayó y aquí el micrófono humano
es esto sí que nosotros no tuvimos que
es el internet
tienen ustedes una
arma muy poderosa positiva hay que
usarla de manera positiva una
herramienta súper poderosa que es su
dispositivo electrónico porque porque es
el mismo libro que a nosotros nos
tardaba en llegar 5 o 6 meses a ustedes
le toca les facilita bajarlo en cinco o
seis segundos esa brecha hay entre
ustedes y nosotros ustedes están parados
en hombros de gigantes si dimensión en
lo si en los sesentas se puso un hombre
en la luna imagínense sin internet
imagínense ustedes lo que pueden llegar
a hacer entonces empieza ese sueño que
lo empiezo a llevar a llevar a llevar
mucho más adelante empezará a devorar
libros de electrónica en las tardes iba
a un taller de electrónica primero a
limpiar aparatos y luego me enseñaron a
soldar etcétera etcétera etcétera
tenemos muy poco tiempo lo voy a resumir
pasó a los 18 años de los 9
a los 18 cuando estoy terminando mi
preparatoria cuando se supone que debo
de prepararme así es esa esa etapa de
nuestra vida académica para lo que sigue
yo seguía con ese sueño yo tenía que
hacer robots entonces acudo con mi
orientadora vocacional le digo que
necesito yo estudiar para hacer robótica
para fabricar diseñar robots la
respuesta de ella fue igual que nueve
años atrás igual de contundente y muy
parecida me dice la orientadora
vocacional si tú quieres diseñar y
construir robots tendrías que estudiar
a eeuu seguía siendo nuestra realidad
como país seguía siendo nuestra realidad
fueron ya en ese entonces imagínense al
niño nueve años que le dicen esto pues
le entra por un oído y le sale por el
otro con muchas cosas que nos dicen los
padres en aquel entonces en aquella edad
pero ya los 18 años yo ya sabía que lo
que me estaban diciendo era
es muy impactante ya lo asimilaba eso ya
lo entendía
y fueron dos días que yo estoy muy
triste incluso por qué no decirlo- un
poco deprimido por eso que me habían
dicho
pero no todo es como que la maestra se
pone las pilas y me vuelve busque me
dice oye guixar
cuando que me preguntaste si hay una
carrera que te puede ayudar a ser
robótica mi hijo es industrial malísimo
yo para las matemáticas todas las
vacaciones me las aplique con maestros
para poder entrar al tecnológico de
culiacán una institución pública
yo soy egresado con mucho orgullo de
puras instituciones públicas así que no
hay diferencia entre ustedes y yo entro
yo a tecnológico de culiacán y que
sucede yo no quería ser el único loco en
la escuela que hiciera robots que
extiendan a ser robots entonces
le comparto el contagio porque es un
contagio a mis compañeros del deseo de
hacer robótica pero una robótica
especial una robótica que ayudará
cruz roja bomberos protección civil
policías y por qué no al ejército
también porque estábamos viviendo un
momento muy turbulento donde había
muchas tomas de rehenes había secuestros
pero en bancos para la toma de rehenes
perdón estoy yo quería algo que se
pudiera mover que pudieran negociar que
pudiera me refiero no el robot sino que
a través del operador pudiera hablar con
las personas que tenían a los rehenes y
pudiera llegarse a una a un buen término
sí y evitar que se siguieran perdiendo
vidas de jóvenes jóvenes militares
jóvenes marinos jóvenes policías que son
los primeros que llegan a un
enfrentamiento esa era mi idea logramos
algo la vida nos fue llevando en mis
amigos se fueron viendo por otros
caminos y me quedé solo terminando este
equipo bueno no esté pero un equipo
parecido a este mucho antes de que
nacieran estos otro bots
me encuentro terminando lo yo solo y
aplicó para una
aplico solicitud para bajar
financiamiento para investigación en
conacyt si no una vez dos tres cuatro
veces dos tres años seguidos y con así
dice no como como en sinaloa vamos a
apoyar algo de robótica no si no lo a
tomates chiles cámara horas pero robots
y sinaloa o por favor pues no llega ese
es el financiamiento pero qué sucede si
alguien ha aplicado para conocido uno
tiene que describir el proyecto
totalmente
y ahí describí yo que es técnicamente mi
sueño que era la robótica de escribí un
motor que había desarrollado yo para que
el motor el robot fuera muy poderoso sus
ruedas
este motor lo hice total y absolutamente
de cero y tiene algunas innovaciones por
ahí bueno
pasan los años sigo yo con el sueño y
tengo que trabajar tengo que pagar
recibos de luz agua teléfono etcétera
estoy trabajando y la vida me lleva a
trabajar muy cerca del alcalde de mi
ciudad a la par yo seguía siendo
robótica en mi casa pero lo hacía de
manera como que escondida porque a decir
en aquel entonces está haciendo robots
es como decir como que está mediatizado
porque hace robots quedar al bato no
entonces yo las escondía pero solamente
un amigo compañero del ayuntamiento
sabía que yo estaba haciendo robótica yo
me encontraba en un estrés impresionante
cuando una mañana que llegó yo a la
oficina me encuentro con un correo
electrónico que dice
felicidades
nasa quiere conocer lo que estás
haciendo en robótica
en aquel entonces había mucho un correo
electrónico
andaba circulando mucho correo
electrónico que decía felicidades
ganaste un viaje a orlando y en un
fraude total y bueno pues era muy
parecido pero decía que nada quería
conocer mis proyectos de robótica
como ven mexicano y crédulo en cierto
sentido
sabiendo que un solo amigo sabía de mí
de mi proyecto pues yo contesto el
correo electrónico pensando que era mi
amigo pero de una manera pues muy
sabrosa
muy norteño porque quizás un compañeros
quieren que le puse no lo puedo repetir
aquí porque es un público decente pero
le puse hijo de gesto me dio más
información mándame laden es estar
jugando de contexto en el que roban en
inglés muy bien muy bonito muy redactado
muy yo digo si a mí me presiona el jefe
y yo lo mando contigo pero no no las
palabras serán mucho más turbia ingrese
su correo electrónico
a los dos días otra vez volvería el
mismo correo electrónico y lo vuelvo a
contestar peor
hijo es total por cual ponte a trabajar
para eso te paga el gobierno
ahorita voy te voy a sacar de tu oficina
etcétera y gente
los regresó pero agarró el teléfono
luego oye deja de
a estar molestando recordarme y espérame
que no te ha mandado nada
tu ciudad no tenía como unos 78 metros
su cubículo y viene conmigo el sí
experto en redes inicial existe para
allá no me dice este correo si venía de
nada saca
bueno dije pues yo al caos que ni quería
ir
allá las personas después de eso ya no a
los dos días sino ya dos horas después y
el otro correo electrónico
en español
dicen este vato no sabe inglés
bueno ya no te estoy viendo el teléfono
y comuníquese con la persona que habla
español y vamos a perder no esté este
individuo no habla inglés perdón no
habla inglés comuníquese con la persa si
va a hablar español
entonces me comuniqué con la persona de
origen sonorense allá en nasa el negocio
disculpe mi nombre es eduardo guisa hay
20 rompe paisano en la que me metiste
acá porque porque soy la única que habla
español en la oficina y me contestas tu
correo en español y lo leemos aquí
este hombre no habla inglés es hablar en
español pues si hablaba inglés y el que
bueno pues discúlpame etcétera etcétera
entonces cuando yo hago ese contacto ya
con asa me solicitan a estar allá me
dejarán para allá con todos los gastos
pagados primero para conocer el proyecto
conocen el motor conocen mi motor y
sirve exactamente para un detalle que
ellos estaban buscando y estoy
trabajando con ellos algunos meses
colaborando con ellos algunos meses iba
y venía a mexico
cuando una tarde me dicen
señor su motor para ir dentro de las
ruedas de el robot mars science
laboratory todavía no se llamaba
curiosity iba a ir a otro planeta es ahí
donde el sueño que empezó en los nueve
años
se cumple pero más allá de cumplirse te
sobrepasa por qué
ese sueño empezó con una película con
robots en otro planeta y yo quería hacer
robots que estuvieran aquí si producto
que se moviera de aquí que ayudaron a la
gente pero mi sueño fue más allá debido
a la a lo que es
a la dedicación la pasión y la
am
pero perseverancia perdón la
perseverancia es que ya está jmsa ya mi
tiempo mis sueños me sobrepasó cachos
fue más allá me ayudó mucho la
disciplina
y ese sueño de mis nueve años lo alcancé
es aquí estoy con algunos de los equipos
ahí en mi piel y quiero concluir con
estos jóvenes los sueños los sueños son
como caballos salvajes este no son
cabeza salvaje me lo cambian pero los
sueños son como caballos salvajes
realmente sí que hay que tomarlos se han
visto ustedes los rodeos donde va un
jinete se sube a un caballo que no está
domesticado y tiene que tomarlo así se
toman los sueños
así se llaman los sueños ese sueño entre
más valga la pena más te va a tumbar no
duda muchas veces pero si tú en una de
esas caídas te quedas tirado en el suelo
y te auto compadece si dices
y no puedo soy muy humilde no tengo la
manera de ir a la universidad no no no
aquí ya no cabe en la autocompasión te
tumba el caballo te levantas te sacude
el pantalón y lo agarras de la cola al
caballo lo agarras del aquí y te subes
de nuevo hasta que lo domésticas hasta
que lo hagas tuyo si tú te quedas tirado
viendo ese caballo va a llegar a alguien
y a medio domesticar se va a subir y
atún tirado en el suelo lo vas a ver
pasaría es decir ese ese era mi sueño si
dos señores tienen que tomarlo por
último a quien los invito a reflexionar
lo siguiente nos podemos comportar de
dos maneras una como una lata de
aluminio si usted es la presión amante
esa presión del diario
y en algún momento ustedes intentan
regresarla a su forma normal y a la
mejor va a medir lo mismo la lata pero
va a estar ya no va a tener su forma
original
o se pueden comportar como resortes que
suceden a hacerse más bajito más pequeño
que a la vista pero que está haciendo el
resorte está absorbiendo energía la
energía que le están aplicando y llegó
un momento que ese resorte rebasa la
energía aplicada
y
sale disparado sale disparado
compórtense mentalizarse como resortes
muchas gracias
[Música]